the protests over police brutality
against black people across the country
can trace their roots to this nation's
history
of racism journalist nicole hannah jones
won the 2020 pulitzer prize for
commentary
as the creator of the 1619 project for
the new york times
the series examined the many
contributions of black americans
and the ways the legacy of slavery
continues to shape america
anna jones is a staff writer for the new
york times magazines and she
joins us from new york city nicole good
morning i i want to
you've talked about the policing of
african americans in this country as
having a very distinct history
can you explain that history
yes thank you for having me on um i
think what's important when you
say we're talking about the legacy of
slavery is to be clear the policing
we're talking about is the policing of
the descendants of those
who this country thought so little of
that uh we enslaved them
for 250 years and then followed that
with a hundred years of racial apartheid
and terrorism
so none of this should be that shocking
and the legacy
is that um the slave patrols
which were brought into existence in
order to
maintain slavery to police insurrections
and to ensure that enslaved people were
always where they were supposed to be
morphed directly into police
particularly in the south and
also into the northeast and during the
time of slavery
it was legal to use lethal force on
enslaved people
for any infraction um if slave people
resisted capture or slave enslaved
people were
in a place where they weren't supposed
to be it was legal to use lethal force
and and we are seeing the ongoing legacy
of that of the type of policing
that black americans get uh is often a
form of social control
and often um the the belief that lethal
force
is justified no matter how petty the
alleged crime
uh nicole i just want to tell our
viewers we were having problem with your
with your shot at froze
we can still hear you though so so we're
going to continue
you wrote on twitter i want to say i
feel like we keep telling this story
over and over again nicole
and you wrote on twitter the cycle of
police killings and black grief and rage
is so regular
i've written the same story several
times how do we
break this cycle
that's a good question i think we're all
grappling for answers to that
um certainly we don't break the cycle by
pretending that it doesn't happen
or that these are just uh individual
actions and not part of larger systemic
systems i think the biggest thing that
we can do
policy wise is actually have
accountability
for officers who use this type of lethal
force since 2005
only about 35 officers have been
convicted of killing citizens
um officers know that there's almost
nothing that they can do for wit to
citizens for which they will face
any type of legal prosecution the trump
administration
immediately upon coming into office
ended consent decrees with
apartments that have been found having
abused citizens
the supreme court has made it almost
impossible to convict officers of crimes
as long as officers say that they feared
for their lives
so we have to hold police accountable i
think the thing that
was most devastating about the video of
george floyd
is how that officer saw that there were
witnesses
and he callously laid on that man's neck
for 8 minutes and 46 seconds
despite there being witnesses and
filming there was no concern whatsoever
that there would be a consequence even
for the use of deadly force and that has
to change
yeah he had a camera in front of him the
whole time at the same time
just this week nicole we've heard the
president's national security advisers
say
he did not believe there was systemic
racism in police departments across the
country
the top new york police department
uniformed officer told tony earlier in
this broadcast
he didn't see systemic racism in the new
york police department
if if we're not hearing officials even
consider that possibility
how do we correct it
i don't even understand how he could
utter those words the
fbi put out a report just a couple of
years ago
raising the alarm about the infiltration
of police forces across this nation by
white supremacist
groups including the klu klux klan so we
know that there is a problem of racism
within police department
it's been documented by the nation's
highest law enforcement office
this is up to citizens to hold law
enforcement accountable and politicians
accountable who want to downplay what is
clearly happening
it is not saying every police officer is
racist that is obvious
but there is a deeply embedded problem
with racism
in the police department and in fact the
role that police departments have played
has been to enforce
uh racial laws and racial policies
against black americans and we still see
that
in how policing happens
all right nicole hannah jones thank you
so much for being with us this morning